le candidat de sondernach fait deux
trois meetings par jour alors dans les
coins les plus reculés de sa
circonscription
[Musique]
si on soit d estrade improvisée
il s'efforce d'abord de lutter contre
l'abstention et ensuite de persuader ses
auditeurs que le chemin vers la
démocratie et hiver mais qu'il faut
respecter dès la tombée du mur c'est
l'étrange un ouvrier est-allemand pas
son marteau à celui de l'ouest pour la
première fois l'ouest et l'est
travailler ensemble
et on finit par oublier on finit par
oublier que l'un derrière il y a encore
des miradors ses policiers et ses vocaux
qui pendant des années ont fait peur et
qui ont tué oui aujourd'hui la vie a
fini par triompher du mur à berlin
[Musique]
après le mur de berlin c'est aujourd'hui
au rideau de fer que s'attaquent les
allemands de l'est à saint georges au
nord de l'allemagne les
gardes-frontières s'acharne à coups de
cisailles contre un dispositif meurtrier
il de fer barbelés électrifiés et
systèmes de mitraillages à déclenchement
automatique
la nouvelle de la démission des
principaux dirigeants du parti
communiste tchèque tombe comme une bombe
au milieu de la conférence du forum
civique alexandre double check et vaclav
havel vont lever leur verre à la
tchécoslovaquie libre
et eu ce depuis coupé en deux place de
la république devant le siège du parti
communiste roumain aux balcons des
orateurs prennent la parole à tour de
rôle ils disent représenter un nouveau
parti d'opposition le parti démocrate
on a parlé
on veut la liberté véritable
est ce que tout cela n'a pas quelque peu
ébranlé vos convictions communistes
fabien roussel
non parce que j'ai pas d'airé aux
particules liste français en référence à
ce qui se passait là bas
est d'ailleurs en france je reconnais
pas le courage qui ont adhéré en
référence à ce qui se passait là bas
c'était pas notre idéal communiste quand
même
staline n'a jamais été notre idéal
communiste alors même nom mais à qui
vous ont précédés oui mais vous me posez
la question à moins moi je suis d'une
génération qui n'a pas grandi dans ce
monde là quand même moi j'ai adhéré au
parti communiste français en référence à
la lutte contre l'apartheid et j'ai
ensuite poursuivi mon engagement par
rapport à des combats que nous avons
menés en france pour la défense de
l'industrie du monde du travail pour la
défense
du monde ouvrier c'était ça mon combat
mais le parti communiste français aussi
a été dans la même période le parti qui
s'est battu contre les guerres
coloniales
contre pour l'indépendance de l'algérie
contre la guerre au vietnam
enfin je veux dire on a été aussi ce
parti est bien seule et bien aussi
parfois le seul à mener ces combats pour
la paix contre les colonies
contre toutes ses formes d'impérialisme
qui existait des deux côtés des deux
blocs américains et soviétiques et ça
fait partie de notre histoire notre
histoire à la tout sépare de lumière et
c'est par aussi dhombres nous les
assumons je les assume c'est pas le cas
de tous les partis y en a beaucoup qui
change des tic est tous les cinq ans ou
tous les dix ans dès qu'ils ont une
affaire au cul c'est pas notre c'est pas
notre cas nous on assume
[Musique]